hello everyone i'm saad omar i'm the
director of yale institute for global
health
in addition to
ygh
we are indebted to the macmillan center
at yale for
co-sponsoring today's event
it's an honor for me to introduce
today's guest
u.s senator chris murphy senator murphy
has been a strong voice
in the senate
fighting for job creation affordable
health care education
um sensible gun laws and a
forward-looking foreign policy
includingly and of particular interest
to us global health
as a member of the
foreign relations committee the health
education labor
and pensions committee appropriately
sort of abbreviated often as the help
committee
um and the appropriations committee
senator murphy has played a key role and
continues to play a key role in policy
making around critical global health
issues
for example he has introduced the global
health security and diplomacy act
gsta
a legislation that
is geared towards better
detection deterrence and containment of
infectious disease outbreaks
overseas before they become global
pandemics
as we will learn more today he had he
was an early champion
for a very robust response to the covert
19
pandemic um and
he
has also uh advocated for a range of
issues in
global health including primary care
tuberculosis and many other issues
we intentionally we initially had the
intention to have an hour long long
program however given the deliberations
that are happening in congress around
budget reconciliation and other issues
i.e senator murphy's day job
our conversation today will be around 30
minutes
while we won't be able to take audience
questions today because of that
change in time
um
i'm looking forward to a great
discussion nevertheless welcome senator
murphy we are so pleased to have you
with us today
uh dr omer thank you very much uh
appreciate you accommodating
my schedule here uh it is a
very busy week in the senate but uh this
is still part of my day job uh working
not only on continuing to improve the
united states response to covid uh
putting ourselves back in a leadership
position globally to help other nations
respond
but also to communicate what we're
working on
to people in connecticut and around the
country so uh grateful for this
opportunity and looking forward to the
conversation my pleasure so so to get us
started can you give us sort of a big
picture view of how the u.s congress
responded to the pandemic
and how it has evolved this response has
evolved uh since the early days of 2020.
but that's uh a uh important question
with a probably hour-long answer and so
i'll give you the very abbreviated
version uh as you mentioned i was uh one
of the earliest critics of the trump
administration's laissez-faire policy
towards coronavirus early on as we all
remember they were making claims that it
would be dispensed within a week or two
uh and put essentially all of their eggs
in one basket that was the travel
restriction basket uh instead of
requesting early emergency funding from
congress
in order to start um building a robust
supply chain and training local
hospital and public health staff around
how to deal with early infections and
the early need to uh track and trace
they put in place what ended up being
effectless set of travel restrictions
that ultimately was easily pierced by
the virus
congress and washington has a deserved
reputation for being defined by gridlock
and stalemate i will say uh 2020
an election year um
was a time of pretty incredible
bipartisan compromise uh on six
different occasions
five six seven half a dozen separate
occasions congress came together
republicans and democrats to pass
significant bipartisan legislation to
address the coronavirus crisis
president trump didn't lead republicans
and democrats in congress led
and so the reason today that you have
small businesses that are still standing
the reason why schools were able to
reopen that's because congress passed
legislation from the cares act through
to the december legislation with both
parties on board to respond to the
crisis
not coincidentally election of joe biden
politics started to creep into
the
question of how the political class
talked about coronavirus we were largely
together through 2020 but all of a
sudden when a democrat came into the
white house republicans started
to raise new issues about
vaccine policy and mask wearing and now
unfortunately many parts of the country
are divided along political lines as to
whether we should follow doctor's advice
and that is a failing of our political
system you know in connecticut i think
we've been lucky that well you still
find politics um there's still a crowd
that doesn't want our kids wearing masks
in school um by and large republicans i
think in connecticut have been you know
at the table responsive and thoughtful
uh and i think that's part of the reason
why connecticut leads the pack
nationally when it comes to vaccination
rates and uh remains at the bottom of
the pack when it comes to infection
rates so
congress i would argue had a pretty good
2020 has not had a very good 2021 in
terms of
bipartisan cooperation on covet and as
we'll talk about my hope is that we
recognize that we have to walk and chew
gum at the same time we've got to
protect ourselves
against uh the current strains of covet
while standing up a global
infrastructure to identify new strains
and future pathogens and that's a lot of
the work that i'm engaged in on the
foreign relations committee and frankly
dr homer we've been very
grateful to have your um advice and
counsel on uh many of the pieces of
legislation that we've been working on
here i'm grateful for our personal
partnership
my pleasure and thanks for highlighting
that you know in democracies uh these
levels of initiatives and
response to crises
are inevitably political but they don't
have to be partisan and i think
we are all served
with by sort of broad engagement on some
of these
major policy policy issues
and you have also been a champion of um
efforts
to reduce the impact of misinformation
and disinformation
during a pandemic but but broadly around
health as well
what do you think
we can specifically do in this area of
reducing the impact of misinformation
and disinformation
well as we all know um the difficulty of
getting square information exists beyond
the health realm i was
two weeks ago
um engaging in my annual walk across the
state i take about a week every year and
i walk from one end of the state to the
other and i was walking through
middletown stopped to see an older
gentleman who was sitting on a bench i
think waiting for a bus
uh and we got a really fascinating
conversation he was a trump voter in
2016. he was a biden voter in 2020 he's
not particularly partisan or political
but his biggest worry
was where he should get good information
he doesn't trust any information sources
these days um he misses the time when
there are only three news
broadcasts when he you know thought that
news was a public contribution of the
networks rather than a source of profit
um and so this is a question that a lot
of americans are having of course you
know when it comes to health
misinformation it's deadly right um you
get the wrong information about politics
maybe that causes you to cast an
ill-informed vote you get the wrong
information about your health
you may not survive there's a pew center
study suggesting that about half of the
american public reports uh having
consumed some amount of misinformation
fraudulent health information uh online
uh and all of us who have run into an
honor and uncle or a friend who tells us
that um you're more likely to die if you
get the vaccine
we know how easy it is to pick up that
information so i really think it's time
for a big investment in health literacy
and i don't think this is a particularly
complicated endeavor because you know
there are a handful of very trusted
sources on both public sector and
private sector sources
and you know engaging in a public
relations effort to just
generally try to explain to people which
sources they can trust and which sources
they can't
i think that that would be really
constructive so i'm building legislation
right now that i've consulted with you
dr omeron i'm trying to win some
bipartisan support for it that would
push this public information campaign
around where to get your health
information from um and we also of
course you know are in a constant
dialogue with these social media
outlets um i will surprise you that
senator bloomball and i are not
satisfied with uh the degree to which
the big platforms like google or
facebook have policed misinformation i
mean i'm watching facebook ads on tv
right now in which they're basically
defending their right to put lies uh on
um on the internet uh and i think that's
just uh devastating for democracy but
also devastating for our covet uh relief
efforts
so switching a little bit to sort of
last year and i'll combine a couple of
um questions together in the sense that
last year as part of our response the
u.s response there were a lot of efforts
to push for
utilization of the defense production
act and some of the other interventions
to improve
not only just domestic ppe supply
personnel for protective equipment
supply as well as make sure that our
allies around the world had ppe and
therapeutics
to reduce the spread of covet 19.
what did those efforts look like and how
should we think differently about our
supply chains going forward and if you
want to elaborate on how you and other
members are approaching sort of broader
response to the pandemic you perhaps you
might want to combine that as well but
but i'm interested in you know in the
context of the defense production act
and and some of the sqli of some of
those events
well first of all the utilization of the
defense production act
for
pandemic response is very much like
trying to take a square peg and fit it
in a round hole
so
while i have been amongst the most vocal
proponents of utilizing the dpa
we just have to remember the gpa is a
sort of wartime initiative
to give the president of the united
states the ability to commandeer
industrial resources in order to make
airplanes
right or whatever you need in order to
fight a foreign enemy it was not
designed
uh
to produce
masks or syringes
and so you know now that we are
getting to the point where we can have
some 2020 vision on 2020.
uh we should be thinking about rewriting
a version of the dpa specifically
tailored for health crises one of the
things we found in 2020 was that the
utilization of the gpa was a mess
largely because donald trump was a mess
but he put it in the hands of his
son-in-law who had no experience running
big supply chains but also because it
inherently asks the department of
defense to take a primary role the
department of defense has no experience
in building these kind of supply chains
and as we learned
the agencies that should have that kind
of expertise cdc
nih and hhs also weren't very good at it
so we've got to sort of build a
permanent capacity inside
the federal government to manage medical
supply chains and yes we need to work
with our allies
in order to build the permanent ability
to produce the most important equipment
uh the most important supplies necessary
we i think we've just got to make a
decision that when it comes to certain
items we can't be reliant on a chinese
supply chain that doesn't mean that you
know we have to be
constantly you know making
gaws or syringes it means that we have
to have the the plus up capacity the
surge capacity
in the united states and our ali
structure uh in order to meet that
demand should another pandemic occur
wonderful so so i think there will be um
hopefully a lot of sort of policy
changes uh some introspection and
hopefully some legislation and and
policy interventions uh not all will of
them will be legislative uh
solutions
how do we ensure that any policy changes
that are made to strengthen our pandemic
preparedness
are maintained beyond the current
administration and and the tools that
the
the tools that are developed through
legislation are actually utilized
well it's always a risk in a democracy
uh that a policy adopted by one
government will be reversed by the uh by
the next um but i think if you look at
the areas of alignment and the areas of
of of distinction between the parties
um it gives you a little window forward
into where we can create policy
consistency and where we can't right now
you see the division that exists on mask
and
vaccine mandates um i don't know that
that's going to be solved anytime soon
but there is alignment when it comes to
some of these questions we were just
discussing like supply chain uh i think
there's a there's a growing agreement
inside the republican party that we need
to have an industrial policy as a nation
uh and that belief sort of comes out of
the experience of covet but it also
comes out of the crisis we've seen with
semiconductors um and other critical
items for the industrial supply chain so
the senate back in the summer maybe late
spring early summer passed a bipartisan
bill that for the first time ever really
advanced a u.s industrial policy we
actually allocated billions of dollars
to help subsidize industry in critical
areas so that we can compete with china
so i i think if we do re-evaluate
some of these issues around supply chain
and readiness
we can guarantee some consistency from
administration of administration
wonderful uh so
you were um one of the early supporters
of u.s engagement and funding for the uh
the coalition for epidemic preparedness
innovations and other similar measures
and and for for our sort of audiences
wouldn't uh not everyone would be
familiar with it it's uh it's it was
this entity created
right around the ebola outbreak 2014
2015 outbreak to speed up uh the
availability of vaccines around the
world especially in low middle income
countries and have those vaccines ready
uh for phase three trials after doing
initial development uh for a while until
very recently until the trump admin
until the biden administration uh
they were funders of that entity that
ranged from
ethiopia to norway and britain in
between
but the u.s was
conspicuous by its absence i know that
you have been an early supporter of that
initiative and similar measures
any thoughts on
going forward how do we look at
initiatives like sepi
um or is there anything else that comes
out of this crisis that fills that gap
i think this is a fascinating and really
important debate
how to properly set up incentive
structures to get safe and effective
vaccines for emerging pathogens as
quickly as possible
i as you mentioned have come to the
conclusion that we need to be invested
in international cooperation and sepi is
in my mind the place to do that
the buy administration has invested but
not enough
trump the trump administration sort of
sat on the sidelines let others invest
in seppi the biden administration has
jumped in but not with two feet uh i
think we can do better i don't think
that that um eliminates um our domestic
ability to you know pursue our own
vaccine pathways i i there's some that
say well we shouldn't be in the business
of international cooperation because
you know coronavirus was actually a
example of how nation v nation
competition expedited the development of
vaccines that everybody knew they had to
do it on their own
there was no guarantee you were going to
be saved by somebody else so there was
massive investment you ended up with
european work u.s work chinese russian
uh work i i don't think it's an it's
it's an either or a question i think
it's a both and i think you can both
develop your own domestic capability to
create a vaccine and be robustly compe
uh cooperating in space like like like
sepi um
and i and i i'm
um
worried about some of my colleagues
ability to
view this uh as a as a two mutually
exclusive uh options so i continue to
you know press the administration to you
know both both plus up uh our domestic
investment in vaccine research and make
a big contribution to sepi i don't think
we can lose if we do both
yeah um so you you have an interesting
uh place you know sort of in our
legislative and policy process
um so in addition to uh
serving on the the health education
labor and pensions or the so-called help
committee you also serve on the
foreign relations committee
from a global health perspective uh you
know
and from a foreign policy perspective
there's a lot of
i would say instability in in the u.s
interaction with china things are
evolving things are changing uh we are
certainly not in the like early 2000s
era in terms of interaction with china
so specifically sort of keeping sort of
those perspectives in mind health and
foreign relations
how do you see um
the balance of competition versus
collaboration with china going forward
well i think the
the the fight over the next 50 years
will be between
u.s style democracy and chinese style
autocracy
the chinese believe that american
democracy and european democracy uh is
withering on the vine
they think that kovit is an example of
how
uh democracy and democratic institutions
have become so sclerotic that they
aren't able to adapt in order to meet
new threats
and well coronavirus began
in china they would argue that their
system was much more effective at
stamping it out obviously at great cost
to civil liberties
uh and so we've got a lot of work to do
at home in order to improve the
state of u.s democracy we have to show
that our democracy can rise to meet the
challenges of today which is you know
why the buildback better agenda that
we're discussing right now
um asking the very wealthy to pay their
fair share to fund investments in the
middle of america i think that's
important to our global competition with
china as our efforts to make sure that
everybody in this country has the right
to vote
but you know maybe
[Music]
on the top five list of devastating
trump-era policies was the decision to
withdraw from the who i mean i don't
know that we will recover from that
decision during the first term of the
biden administration because china
having become the biggest player there
in our absence isn't going to give up
that position of hegemony uh easily uh
they are
right now the biggest contributor to
many u.n agencies um the un feels that
china is a more reliable donor
often than
the united states is
so as we try to compete with china's we
try to make sure that u.s health
regulations
u.s and european health standards
become the rules of the road we've got
to be present in a big way in these
multilateral bodies and so this is a
time
and i'm arguing this at the foreign
relations committee for the united
states to double down on our
participation in these organizations
that's one way that we
step up to the plate on china
competition
so as you know that we have had cyclical
interest
a boom and bust cycle of public health
funding in this country
public health departments uh you know we
were very fortunate in connecticut uh
for our state leadership um in terms of
getting the job done with the pandemic
especially the immunization program and
so and so forth but generally speaking
the the capabilities of the health
departments have been eroded
substantially because of these partially
because of these boom and bust cycles
are there any maybe it's too early to
ask that question but has there been any
thinking to get out of that
to use policy levers that add
predictability
to
some of those resources
that health departments specifically but
also federal agencies like the cdc etc
can can expect
i was just having this discussion this
morning in my office with uh kathy
siller who's the ceo of the stanford
hospital health system
she was talking about a really
impactful model that they created and
uh disseminated around stanford to try
to get vaccines into uh low-income and
non-english-speaking communities they
have an extraordinary success rate and
you know to her mind it was and it was a
really important collaboration between
the hospital
public health
the city
local health nonprofits
and you know they were successful in
those low-income neighborhoods and
getting 81 vaccine penetration which is
really
uh remarkable um better than we've seen
in many other uh like neighborhoods
throughout the state and country
but
that's because we funded that effort
right that's because we decided to spend
billions of dollars in relatively
flexible funding so that stanford
hospital could design
uh yale new haven could design
public health programs that
empowered public health professionals to
spend the time that was necessary with
people to get them into the necessary
program in this case the program was
simple a shot in your arm in other cases
the
programs are more complicated whether it
be recovery programs or uh mental health
treatment programs but the tools are the
same public health workers um out there
in the community working outside of a
fee-for-service structure
in a coordinated way
so
your question is whether we've learned
lessons here and i think the answer is
we haven't i mean right now there's not
the kind of talk there should be in
replicating some of the models we use
for vaccine distribution for addiction
for
mental health for obesity
um and that's really
a missed opportunity um
so i'll continue to make that case but i
will say you know a lot of this has to
come from the grass roots up right now
there's so
little
accountability when it comes to
public health everybody's doing it and
and we've just from the top down we've
designed that system but you know we
need some help from practitioners on the
ground to say how would we redesign this
system right now public health districts
are doing it city governments are doing
it hospitals are doing it community
health centers are doing it sometimes
they're doing it together in some cities
they're not coordinating at all and so
when you have such siloed public health
work it does make it difficult for the
funders the federal government to decide
to come in and throw more money at it so
giving us a view as to you know how we
can
build integrated systems might make the
federal funders more interested in
putting significant money in
so just to wrap things up um you know
moving forward
uh if you know what will you and the
congress be focusing on to prepare for
the next pandemic something you know
perhaps you haven't mentioned yet or you
know something that you want to
emphasize as we wrap up
well i'd hit the highlights of our
conversation right we've got to combat
health misinformation we've got to
rebuild our
supply chains we've got to continue to
try to do work to de-politicize
the conversation
around uh healthcare and science
but to
finish we've got to understand that if
we're not fighting
pathogens everywhere um we're vulnerable
here uh so we've got to make a big
commitment to global public health uh in
this congress uh i i wrote as you
mentioned the uh first sort of
bipartisan bill rebuilding our global
public health infrastructure jim risch
is a hyper conservative senator at the
time the chairman of the foreign
relations committee from idaho he and i
wrote this legislation together
a version of it was passed by the
foreign relations committee earlier this
year
and you know we are just badly
misresourced right now um we spend
um you know 12 to 20 billion dollars a
year in global public health we spend
700 billion dollars a year on
conventional military construction
that is not the right ratio uh given the
ratio of threats that are presented to
the united states so we've got to
rebuild our public our international
public health platform we've got to
spend more money on it
because if we don't uh we can build up
all the prophylactics back here at home
as we saw in 2020
there's no barrier there's no wall
there's no travel restriction that can
stop a deadly and contagious virus from
hitting us hard
so so thank you uh for a wonderful
conversation and answer i must say that
i think we are fortunate that you know
we have a senator who has his ear to the
ground by things like sort of walk
across
connecticut and we feel fortunate and
i'm i i think you might also feel
fortunate that you represent connecticut
not california because that would have
been a much longer walk um
yeah and i cheated this year i i
normally go east to west which is about
110 miles but
this year given in part the schedule in
washington i went north to north to
south so yeah i have it a lot easier
than most of my colleagues
all right now thank you and thank you to
the uh to those who connected uh to this
call i might i want to remind those who
are
uh sort of present our audiences that
our next conversation event will be with
the doctor angeli
ashrieker the acting uh u.s global aids
coordinator and special representative
for global health diplomacy we look
forward to seeing you again soon and
thanks again senator